coo in your opinion what are some of the
best documentaries on the craft of
filmmaking that's a good question I you
know we talk about a lot of
documentaries and books on no film
school that's kind of part of the
philosophy behind the site is that it
you know if you don't have money to go
to film school or if you're not
someplace where they have a film school
in nearby that you can get to that you
can learn a lot of the stuff through
documentaries through books through
websites like mine and like yours to me
my favorite learning tool for filmmaking
as far as things that are accessible to
anybody anywhere has just been listening
to directors commentaries on DVDs I
think you really get into the shoes of
the person making the creative decisions
and you can you can win a lot that way
so that's been sort of my documentary
about filmmaking that I've sort of
professionally been watching it's just
listening to the directors that I admire
talk about you know why they made this
decision of the challenges of the shoot
are you know working with that actor and
the kind of onset you know or not even
just on set and and from from
pre-production all the way through
delivery you know they talk about these
things in the documentaries I mean in
the commentaries so that's kind of the
documentary it's made it that I've liked
a lot
you